l'émission joumaa des faits divers alors
mais c'est génial c'est pas du
divertissement haut débit
ces audiences où la référence
franchement je vous jure j'ai pas vu non
je vais le découvrir la chance
je te jure je n'ai rien vu je voulais
pas je voulais découvrir en plateau pour
te donner mon avis je te le dirais
franchement non mais j'ai vu moi c'est
le bâtard se l'est vu ba est bon on va
tout de suite donc vous montrer des
images que ce nouveau programme
c'est le journal mais je ne les ai pas
vus arrêter ça donne envie
bah oui faut nous dit ce que vous en
avez pensé et moi aussi j'ai hâte de
voir autour des gens et bien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais regarde utiliser et et vous baume
regarde également alors je découvre avec
vous machin je vais vous donner mon avis
ce sens et c'est un plaisir et un
honneur c'est parti muni de son
téléphone et de son calepin gilles
verdez a donné hier le coup d'envoi de
son journal des faits divers un rendez
vous quotidien d'une cinquantaine de
minutes avec au sommaire des histoires
macabres deux fillettes de 3 et 5 ans
ont été retrouvées mortes le décès d'un
garçon de 5 ans dans un accident
d'ascenseur vendredi une femme qui a tué
son mari à coups de déambulateurs des
images spectaculaires
un petit garçon la tête coincée entre
les barreaux du balcon se balance au
dessus du vide au cinquième étage
un témoin a alerté par les cris est ce
qu elle a de la façade des duplex avec
un très léger décalage alors olivier que
sait-on des faits
des spécialistes qui ont le même
orthophoniste que jean michel maire une
trentaine de gendarmes sont abri son
travail dans la région une compétition
mais elle peut être et par doris qu'ils
aimeraient y est mais aussi une régie
très réactive pour lancer la pub
après la mort vendredi d'un enfant de
cinq ans dans un accident d'ascenseur
nous irons dans le nord où laure sézanne
à 12 ans a disparu
[Musique]
côté audience le journal des faits
divers a démarré timidement avec 32
mille téléspectateurs devant ses news
[Musique]
c'est une nouvelle émission en voilà les
faits divers sur ces 8 sur ces news au
dieu soit loué
on rigole gilles pas mal de ce que j'ai
vu à la rochelle a refait parler agi
honnêtement la jouer sérieux deux
minutes
il est très sérieux trop c'est le nom
qu'on leur connaît pas parce qu'on
connaît de lui dans tpm paix maintenant
qu'il faut qu'ils soient plus gilles
verdez dans ses interviews mais encore
qui présente franchement c'est pas mal
ça fait la blague d'un sommet de la
loire